so tomorrow the Senate is set to vote on
that $118 billion border security bill
which House GOP leaders including our
next guest says is already dead on
arrival but the border patrol Union and
CBP had disagree acting CBP commissioner
Troy Miller saying quote this proposed
legislation will provide the strongest
set of tools we have seen in decades
House Majority Leader Steve scal joins
us now uh Majority Leader thanks so much
for joining the program I went through
my list of issues yesterday with the
bill but it seems like the border patrol
Union disagrees as well as CBP uh why is
that well Lawrence there's a whole host
of issues that we have with this bill
and if you look at where we started in
the house over six months ago hr2 is a
bill that we put together working with
border patrol agents working with others
we've been down to the Border ourselves
personally almost all of us in the house
and ultimately what we recognized was
it's it's the magnet of catch and
release uh it's the broken Asylum
process it's the ending of the remain in
Mexico policy that we want to restore
that would ultimately close the border
what are the things uh that we can do to
secure America's border that's wide open
right now anybody that looks at the
border knows it's wide open and if you
look at the Senate bill it it in essence
codifies catch and release it allows for
more people to come in illegally uh it
makes it easier to make Asylum claims
uh in America again the process for
Asylum has always been there it's a
generous process but you're supposed to
make those Asylum claims in your home
country you don't come into America
through Mexico or through any other
state uh whether it's coming in through
Texas whether it's coming through
California uh what we're seeing right
now is just a complete abuse of the
process because Joe Biden allowed that
to happen Joe Biden could end this today
let's be clear he has the legal
Authority as president to close secure
the Border himself he's chosen not to
and so that's why we took strong action
in the house with hr2 yeah some people
say he broke it he should be able to fix
it as well something that's also
concerning uh Mr leader is that these
Chinese migrants that are coming across
the border illegally UH 60 Minutes did a
report on this where this shows The Tick
Tock they are using let's
watch we wondered how all of these
migrants knew about this particular
entryway into California the answer was
in their hands
oh TI to oh you learned on Tik Tok yeah
Tik Tok is a social media platform
created in China the post we found had
step-by-step instructions for hiring
Smugglers and detailed directions to
that hole we visited you know I just
find it fascinating Tik Tok blocks
everything else from their public from
seeing in China but they're letting them
they're giving them the tools to cross
the border illegally what's the reaction
yeah laurren shouldn't that tell you
everything you need to know that's a
spot in San Diego by the way that 60
Minutes did the feature on last year
over 30,000 Chinese Nationals came
across and they're using Tik Tok which
is controlled by the Chinese Communist
party so if anybody wonders where this
is coming from you know all the
countries what we've documented well
over 150 countries uh where people have
come across our border this isn't just
South and Central America it's Middle
Eastern countries it's China it's other
Asian Nations
all coming into America untethered
without any vetting at all because Joe
Biden sent the Clarian call and said the
borders open come on in and oh by the
way that Senate border Bill puts over a
billion dollars of your additional tax
money to process more people illegally
and to send them out throughout the
country nobody knows where they're going
no Governor can tell you how many are in
each of their states we have mayors that
are crying out Democrat Mayors saying
stop this because it's overwhelming
their cities this is going to bring more
people into those communities yeah but
those say Mayors wanted to be Sanctuary
city as well so they're dealing with the
consequences of their actions real
quickly though Mr leader the secretary
uh mayor orcus DHS uh is expected you
guys are going to do a vote as early as
today uh what are the tea leaves on
that yeah that vote's going to happen
this evening around 6 o'clock uh
secretary my orcus the case has been
made very strongly that he should be
impeached uh chairman green and his
homeland security committee members have
laid this case out over months
and these are many different times where
the secretaries come before the
committee made false statements how many
times has he said the border secure are
given other statements to the committee
that just don't mes up with the facts
and ultimately he's got a job to secure
our nation he's failed miserably that's
why it's risen to this level of a he's
just not doing his job uh Mr real
quickly before we let you go I know the
folks in Louisiana we've been praying
for you how are you
feeling uh feeling great and I
appreciate it I field the prayers uh you
know getting healthier every day and you
know when I saw the story about King
Charles pray I pray for him too because
you know cancer affects so many people
everywhere uh you know it surely
affected me but I I I appreciate the
prayers and the the marvels of science
you know we've made so many advances
we're going to continue to make advances
and uh you know the key is just follow
your doctor's advice hopefully you catch
it early if you find something wrong
with your body go see your doctor
because early detection truly does save
lives well Mr leader you know uh from
Texas Louisiana is right there and we
know that you guys are Fighters as well
uh thanks so much for getting up on on
this program this
morning great being with you Lawrence
thanks God bless you too I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis